you bidding our guest today as Germany's
best known feminist Ally shot sir we'll
be talking about Islam and women's
rights welcome hello you come up in
welcome to the DW interview I'm talaash
spa enshroud sir who was the most
important man in your life haha Mike was
my grandfather was good soul he raised
me I grew up with my grandparents on my
Northland my grandmother read a lot and
she talked about politics and my
grandfather had a very maternal side of
course a maternal grandfather and
political grandmother yeah it was
unusual so in their way they fulfilled a
feminist ideal overcoming rigid gender
roles she did yeah does come as a thief
that's right by the way I think that
this early formative experience got me
thinking hey men can be emotional in
nurturing and women can study politics
it had a big influence on me couldn't
put interesting by fellows finish the
van and Cheyenne Capri it's it if
there's been a lot of progress in
women's emancipation over the last 50
years you've contributed to it your new
book deals with the sexual assaults in
cologne on New Year's Eve were those
crimes the result of a misguided
immigration policy fafi to time you got
salon's political oh yes but not only
that first it became very clear to me as
the details started to come out that
there were parallels to what happened
unto rear square in cairo in 2011 so
mark when women were attacked by mobs in
the same way well yeah it's 5,000 ft
found masson after a fine one with a guy
thing with ordered thousands of men
individuals and little groups swooped
down on the women surrounded them and
assaulted them the parallels were
apparent immediately and we soon found
out that the Cologne assailants came
from Muslim cultures men are similar
mission kwadwo kies
the tatt saw her like that what
surprised me about this situation is
that the perpetrators appear to have
been almost exclusively refugees and
illegal immigrants that's helped me see
it washed I was also amazed that the
police kept everything quiet for so long
and I was surprised by the behavior of
some politicians so the police didn't
intervene and the politicians may even
have attempted a cover-up person why was
that this is in its failed integration
we don't judge the people who come to us
by the same standards we don't tell them
that the rights to which they are
entitled come with some responsibilities
that's authentic about instead we
tolerate a double standard well they're
Muslims that's how they are their
daughters can't go to the disco and
their wives don't leave the house and so
forth detect a leak in the disco the
phone come in the awesome house that's
all nonsense yeah what's more the
majority of Muslims including those who
live among us have been taken over by
this radical minority the Islamists and
politicized Islam does mandy oscar
difficulties ahora con minda height then
islamist i make a very clear distinction
about that these people were not
protected from the radicals and we
weren't protected from the radicals
either that would let's enter 0 points
yet snitched foreign body conscious
about were the perpetrators in Cologne
Islamists minute yeah yes because it's
clear that they came from an Islamic
culture guys we know that they behaved
unusually disrespectfully toward the
police that goes 5 they clearly don't
recognize the authority of the police
guys and the regard women as subhuman
would that mention that they believe
that women who were on the street at
night are [ __ ] and should be treated as
such that's the philosophy of political
Islam to place Sharia law above
constitutional law and to make women
subordinate to men who follow but not
every perpetrator in cologne was a
card-carrying member of some group
Angus Lena Smith if I saw signs but I'd
like to but that is what political Islam
has to offer Muslim men today you're not
just some stupid loser on the corner you
can become a holy warrior but especially
talking lots of Muslim men here in
Germany believe that women should be
subordinate to men they get it from the
Quran and patriarchal family structures
all not all of these people are
Islamists are they known as a no first I
think this is no longer the case in most
Muslim families and also widen and Islam
covers a broad spectrum this hadiqa de
end is at the radical end of the
spectrum is the self-proclaimed Islamic
state which is overrun entire countries
it's vitae then there are the agitators
who are paid by Saudi Arabia and are
trained in Iran or Pakistan when you're
Louis was Juliet from Johan or a
Pakistan they go into Muslim communities
in Europe and insight young men they say
you don't need to learn anything you're
already worth more than women and
infidels gulabi Dilfer they pay families
to make their daughters wear a hijab
divide us and we have Muslims who
believe in sharia law and live in the
past they have hook hrvatska vanpooling
the off they're the ones who often
dominate in the muslim associations in
europe so there's no clear boundary
between Muslim and Islamist but I would
speak of Sharia Muslims if they believe
that Sharia law is superior to
constitutional law I'm Muslim vigas
actor shia but a sketched it and it
gotta be met Samantha regardless of what
you call it what is the future of Islam
in Germany will there be more incidents
like those in Columbus of hidden side
cologne was not only a shock for us
Germans it was a shock for the whole
world when Germans travel overseas
everyone asks them what happened in
Cologne that's why this look so what did
happen i miss back home up to 2,000 men
stood around while groups of men
individuals assaulted more than 600
women that's the number of complaints
that have been filed for hours the law
broke down completely in that part of
town the police didn't intervene and
that was a shock we've never seen that
before we've had sexual violence in
families sometimes at the disco or at
oktoberfest by individuals or even
groups but it's unprecedented for large
numbers of men to drive women off the
streets like this thanks for miles
austin isn't even home to the time but
say gets missing is what we have to do
now is correct our policy and start
actively integrating the Muslims who
live here we have to counteract the
propaganda of these extremist activists
the city's NASA woman their propaganda
they are happening is empty and we have
to take a closer look at the hundreds of
thousands of refugees who are coming to
us to escape war and often the violence
of the Islamists gonna be this big that
doesn't sound much like the ideal
multicultural society where people can
do what they like what absolute
absolutely human rights are inviolable
on the mat and the majority of the
refugees don't come to us because we're
the first port in a storm they've placed
their hope in us they want the rule of
law and democracy of course some of the
men need a bit of remedial instruction
they come from countries where women
have no rights women in Islamic
countries are the equivalent of miners
rows and columns in Islam Elaine man one
man [ __ ] in the opinion they're
dependent on their fathers brothers or
husbands don't didja tighten the Humvee
octave horn right Aaron in this way
women's rights advocates here in the
West have worked hard to put a stop to
all that there are still a few problems
that we have to deal with we can give
the refugees some time to adjust that's
but there is no place here for men who
think they can force women off the
streets these are menahan balls
noosaville what's everyone let's talk a
little about you personally
your ideas have generated a lot of
discussion and you're politically active
you've brought about some major changes
but what was your biggest mistake the
tax evasion case nope nine that's it
something no that has nothing to do with
the things I stand forth so that's mrs.
Sheppard spirally can see da Gama I made
a mistake with my taxes and I paid a big
price for it focus I was ridiculed in
the media in any case it has nothing to
do with my personal politics petechiae
Connie Satori months it deep some of
your colleagues might say that your
comments on refugees and Muslims in
Germany sound like they might have come
from the right wing extremist movement
pegida does not bother him dau sad did
she doesn't speak famous kind of oil is
Indian no in fact the opposite is the
case for decades all the political
parties have ignored or played down the
problem of politicized Islam not Islam
per se that's religion so it's a private
and personal matter numatic nice to meet
in Islam this is a global prophet saw
the problematic but we need to be aware
of the effects and excesses of political
Islam 06 endorphin ignore via Tom oh duh
forgot a harmless and I think this is
the main reason why for the first time
in germany since 1945 we unfortunately
have strong right-wing populists and
even right-wing extremist movements
enough vodka effects for police to show
one toga fixed extremist women so yeah
we Democrats have failed to address
public concern about these developments
that's so the right-wingers have picked
it up dimensionally but is in fig jam it
was all Qaeda freedom asleep and many
Muslims are upset too they write to
congratulate me for finally telling it
like it is yeah we've driven people into
the right-wing camp site that's the old
it's high time that we put a stop to
this sham policy of tolerance and begin
treating the Islamists who are after all
the fascists of the 21st century the
same way we treat right-wing extremists
because that's what they are no more
sham tolerance we need integration
policies that are genuine and proactive
Porsche lots of it miss Schwartz are at
the end of our interview we ask our
guests to complete three sentences
batons ed dragons no that's the worst
men not I tell men who think I'm
humorless sagas I laugh at them isn't
we're sitting in a medieval fault here
in the Middle Ages I would have got up
spin mastercraft women that's a solid
profession they had them here in Cologne
good from women in Germany I expect does
he is that they know a that they
sometimes have to make compromises you
can't have everything you can't always
have both a family and a brilliant
career and B they need to make demands
on their men hmm don't always talk to
men as if they were children to be
humored that's just how he is I'll have
to find a way to manipulate him my lord
they should hash things out with the men
as equals I'll being always with their
men allows nagas it's hellish Watson
thanks for joining us thank you thank
you